I got my teeth cleaned this week, and I was asking the hygienist how it was going with the global pandemic and all. And she was like, just yesterday somebody stole two face masks from the counter right there. And so I was like, do you know who? And she was like, yeah, she knew exactly who, because she caught her red handed, and the woman wasn't sorry at all-- wouldn't give the masks back. I mean, there's a national shortage, but still.
这周我刚洗了牙，顺便问了下牙科保健员，在这场全球疫情之下工作感觉如何。她说，就在昨天，还有人从柜台上直接偷走了两个口罩。我问她知不知道是谁，她说她很清楚，因为当场就把人抓住了，那女的根本没表现出歉意，也不肯把口罩还回来。我的意思是，全国现在口罩短缺，但即便如此也不该这样。
I heard about this woman, Kim, who decided a couple weeks ago to buy some face masks for her mom. Her mom works at a home caring for the elderly, and face masks are recommended for people like her mom. Kim went shopping for some. CVS-- sold out. Rite Aid-- sold out. Target-- sold out. She called pharmacies around town in northern California, where she lives. No luck, until she reached this one woman.
我听说有个叫金的女士，几周前想给妈妈买些口罩。她妈妈在一家养老院工作，这类口罩是推荐给像她妈妈这样的人佩戴的。金去买的时候，CVS卖光了，Rite Aid卖光了，塔吉特也卖光了。她给北加州住处附近的药店都打过电话，但都没货，直到她联系上一位女士。
She said they were sold out, and then she paused for a second. And then she said, well, I have a stash at home. I might be able to sell you some masks. Let me call you after work.
她说没货了，然后停顿了一下，接着说，不过我家里有些存货，或许可以卖给你一些，下班后再打给你。
Wait, and so suddenly it's like you're doing an illegal drug deal or something over a mask?
等等，这感觉怎么突然像是在做某种口罩的非法毒品交易一样？
Kind of felt that way. So I called her after work. We set up a time and place, and we met the following day in front of the Safeway, next to the Glacier water bottle vending machine.
确实有点那种感觉。我下班后给她打了电话，约好了时间和地点，第二天我们在西夫韦超市（Safeway）门口的冰川牌瓶装水自动贩卖机旁见了面。
Wait, wait.
等等，等等。
And--
然后——
Wait, that's what she said? She said, OK, we're going to meet in front of this Safeway in front of the Glacier bottle vending machine?
等等，她真是这么说的？她说，好，我们就在西夫韦超市门口的冰川瓶装水自动贩卖机前见？
Yes. I found her easily, gave her the cash, got the box, said thank you--
对。我很轻松地找到了她，给了钱，拿到了盒子，说了谢谢——
Now, describe the actual physical transaction. Now, when you handed her the cash, was it a kind of like your hand was over top of the cash so someone else couldn't see it, and she palmed it away from you.
现在，描述一下实际的交易过程。当你把现金递给她的时候，是不是那种把手盖在钱上面以免被别人看见，然后她又从你手里把钱顺走的动作？
Pretty much, yeah.
差不多就是那样。
The woman asked for $100 for 10 masks. Kim talked her down to $70. Regular price would be $1 per mask, maybe $2.
那个女人要价100美元买10个口罩，金最后砍价到70美元。正常价格应该是一个口罩1美元，顶多2美元。
And she told me that she had two boxes left. So if I wanted more, I could come back.
她告诉我她还剩两盒，如果我还想要的话，可以再来找她。
I work at a local co-op here in Seattle, Washington called PCC Community Markets, just a little bit different clientele. They're kind of like a Whole Foods clientele, a little more particular.
我在西雅图的一家当地合作社PCC社区市场工作，那里的顾客群体不太一样。他们有点像全食超市（Whole Foods）的顾客，稍微更挑剔一些。
Cameron works in the produce department, and he's a cashier. Washington state, you may know, has more cases than any other state, and most of them are around Seattle. So the co-op started selling out of toilet paper, beans, flour, hand sanitizer when this first hit the news.
卡梅伦在农产品部门工作，也是一名收银员。大家可能知道，华盛顿州的病例比其他任何州都要多，而且大多集中在西雅图。所以当新闻刚报道疫情时，合作社的卫生纸、豆子、面粉和洗手液就都卖光了。
It's been pretty tense, very just on edge. A lot of people are upset that we don't have hand sanitizer wipes for our carts. I've had a few customers vocally yell at me because of how I was touching their cans when I was checking them out at the register.
气氛一直很紧张，大家都如履薄冰。很多人对我们购物车没有消毒湿巾感到不满。因为我在收银台结账时触碰了顾客的罐头，还有几位顾客对我大吼大叫。
Like this one guy, who had a lot of cans.
就像有个家伙，买了很多罐头。
It was a kombucha energy drink. I can't remember the exact brand. He probably had a couple dozen. Some of them had fallen over, and I'd grabbed the top of the can versus the bottom of the can when scanning it, which, I mean, I can understand. But at the same time, I probably wasn't the first person to touch that can, so.
那是一种康普茶能量饮料，我不记得具体牌子了。他可能买了二三十罐。有些倒了，我扫描时抓的是罐头顶部而不是底部，说实话，我能理解他的想法。但同时，我想我也不是第一个碰到那罐头的人吧。
What did they say to you?
他们对你说了什么？
He just wanted me to be aware of what I was doing. It took me a minute to understand what he was saying, because he was so frustrated. I don't remember the exact words, but paraphrasing he was asking me in a pretty passive aggressive way why I'm touching the cans the way I am.
他只是想让我注意自己的动作。我花了一会儿才明白他的意思，因为他当时非常沮丧。我不记得原话了，但转述一下，他用一种相当消极且具有攻击性的方式问我，为什么要那样拿罐头。
Somehow that's exactly what I would have pictured. I'm picturing sort of Fred Armisen in Portlandia.
不知为何，这场景我完全能想象得到。我脑子里浮现出《波特兰迪亚》里弗雷德·阿米森的样子。
You're so spot on it's gross right now. [LAUGHS] He was wearing glasses, for sure, and some sort of fleece. But he was just telling me how I need to be touching the cans without touching the tops, and yeah.
你形容得太到位了，简直让人反感。[笑声] 他肯定戴着眼镜，穿着某种抓绒衣。他就是在教育我以后拿罐头不能摸顶部，总之就是这样。
Some people have more to fear than others right now, I think, like Jasmine Reese. She works at Los Angeles airport, LAX, cleaning out planes after they land, including international flights. Coronavirus became a very real thing to her over a month ago when a plane arrived from Hong Kong.
我觉得现在有些人比其他人更恐慌，比如贾思敏·里斯。她在洛杉矶机场工作，负责在飞机降落后清理机舱，包括国际航班。一个多月前，一架从香港飞来的飞机降落时，新冠病毒对她来说变成了一件非常现实的事。
Even as I'm getting on the plane, and I see first class, business, I'm walking down. And I'm seeing co-workers with face masks, and I'm like, what's going on? Why does everybody have a face mask? They're like, oh, because there's a virus. There's a virus, and you have to clean this plane. This is one of the planes that, you know, this is Hong Kong. And I'm like, oh, let me go downstairs and go get me one, because keep in mind that I'm five months pregnant.
即便在我上飞机时，我看到了头等舱和商务舱，我往下走，看到同事们都戴着口罩，我心想，怎么了？为什么每个人都戴口罩？他们说，哦，因为有病毒。有病毒，你得清理这架飞机。这可是香港飞来的飞机之一。我心想，哦，让我下楼去拿一个，因为别忘了我怀孕五个月了。
And did they have face masks? Were you able to get one?
那他们有口罩吗？你拿到了吗？
Yeah, but we don't have them every day, and we work every day, but we're kind of low on supply, so meaning that we may not have face masks every day. We may not have gloves every day.
有，但不是每天都有，我们每天都要工作，但供应有点短缺，意思就是我们可能不是每天都有口罩。我们可能不是每天都有手套。
There have been days since the virus when you went in, and you had to clean a plane without a mask?
自病毒爆发以来，有没有哪天你进去工作，却不得不没戴口罩清理飞机？
Yeah, there's plenty. There's plenty of days that we get on there and we don't have no mask. We're cleaning. Sometimes we get on there. We don't have masks and gloves.
有，很多次。很多天我们上去清理时都没有口罩。有时候我们上去清理，既没有口罩也没有手套。
One job the crew does-- they reach deep into garbage bags on the plane and pull out the garbage by hand. Jasmine cleans American Airlines planes. She works for a contractor called Jetstream Ground Services. A number of Jetstream employees have been quoted in the press saying the same thing about gloves and masks that Jasmine says.
机组人员有一项工作——他们得伸手进飞机上的垃圾袋里，用手把垃圾掏出来。贾思敏清理的是美国航空的飞机。她为一家叫Jetstream地勤服务的承包商工作。媒体多次援引多名Jetstream员工的话，说的都是和贾思敏一样关于手套和口罩的问题。
We reached out to a spokesperson for the company, Eric Rose. He said in emails, quote, "we are at a loss as to why the employees are making these false claims." Jetstream Ground Services has always had an abundant supply of safety equipment for all employees to fulfill their daily assignments." End quote.
我们联系了该公司发言人埃里克·罗斯。他在邮件中写道，引用如下：“我们不解为何员工会提出这些不实指控。Jetstream地勤服务公司一直为所有员工提供充足的防护设备，以完成他们的日常工作。”引用结束。
Just this week, the Service Employees International Union started distributing masks and gloves to workers like Jasmine in LAX, saying Jetstream has not properly provided them. The day I talked to Jasmine, two people who work at LAX had at that point tested positive with the virus. Jasmine thought one of them worked at terminal seven.
就在本周，服务业雇员国际工会开始向贾思敏等洛杉矶机场的员工分发口罩和手套，称Jetstream没有为他们提供妥善的保护。在我与贾思敏交谈的那天，洛杉矶机场有两名员工当时已经确诊感染了病毒。贾思敏认为其中一人在七号航站楼工作。
So we have a person all the way down at seven that got sick, and then now they're saying a person, I think, from terminal five was sick. We're at four.
所以七号航站楼已经有一个人病倒了，现在他们又说五号航站楼也有人病了。我们在四号。
Damn.
天哪。
So we're right next to a person that could have possibly came to the food court at our terminal, you just never know.
所以我们离一个可能去过我们航站楼美食广场的人很近，你永远不知道会发生什么。
Do you feel like it's only a matter of time before somebody you work with gets sick?
你觉得你身边的人病倒只是时间问题吗？
Yeah, it's how it's going, and it's on the news, and it's spreading so wide. I wouldn't be surprised if someone-- if the news popped up and said somebody is sick within the next week or two. I could be walking around with a co-worker right now, and they probably have it. You don't know that they have it.
是的，情况就是这样，新闻里都在报，而且传播范围这么广。如果新闻突然报道说未来一两周内有同事病倒了，我一点也不会惊讶。我现在走来走去，身边的同事可能就已经感染了，你根本不知道谁带毒。
So when you're cleaning planes, is this what you're thinking about all the time?
所以当你清理飞机时，你一直在想这个问题吗？
If it's internationally, yes. I'm thinking, why do you have clean this plane? And I'm trying not to stress on it too hard.
如果是国际航班，是的。我在想，为什么我非得清理这架飞机？我尽量不去想得太沉重。
And I can't totally tell. How worried are you?
我完全看不出来，你有多担心？
Truth-- I'm very worried, but I've still got to work and get my money. I have to survive, yes, but I am very worried about it, certainly because I am pregnant.
说实话，我非常担心，但我还得工作赚钱。我得生存，是的，但我确实非常担心，尤其是因为我怀孕了。
Right now as I'm saying these words to you, dozens of people have already died in our country, but somehow it still feels like the calm before the storm. For now, it's like streets are a little emptier, store shelves are emptier. Some people are working from home. Some schools close. Other schools-- everybody's waiting to hear if they're going to be called off. Things are not as awful as they're certainly going to get, so we're all waiting for it to get awful, with no idea of how awful that's going to be.
就在我跟你说这些话的时候，国内已经有几十人死亡了，但不知为何，感觉仍然像是暴风雨前的宁静。现在，街道稍微空了一些，商店货架也空了一些。有些人居家办公，有些学校关门了。其他学校——大家都在等通知是否会停课。情况还远没有到一定会变得那么糟糕的地步，所以我们都在等着那最糟糕的时刻到来，却完全不知道那到底会有多糟糕。
If I had to say what this feels like, I think to me what this feels like is-- I don't know-- the only experience I've ever had like this is sort of like waiting for medical results, trying to find out how bad things are going to be, but on a global scale. We're going to be documenting more about coronavirus in upcoming shows, but for today's show, we thought we would stick to this one part of things, this low hum of menace.
如果非要说这种感觉是什么，我想我唯一有过类似经历的情况，就是等待医疗检查结果的时候，想知道病情到底会有多严重，只不过这次是全球范围的。我们在接下来的节目中会记录更多关于新冠病毒的内容，但今天的节目，我们想先关注这件事的这一面——那种低沉的威胁感。
Here in our staff we were talking about when else does somebody actually feel that feeling? And we found some examples of that to share with you, and that's going to be our show today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们的员工也讨论过，人们到底是在什么时候真的会有这种感觉？我们找到了一些案例来分享，这就是我们今天的节目。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One-- Do You Hear What I Hear? So this first story is about a recording that captures this exact thing today's program is about, that low hum of menace. The recording was made secretly by a woman trying to catch a man who'd been harassing her. Heads up to listeners, this story is about sexual harassment, so there's some sexual content to this.
第一幕——我听到的你听到了吗？第一个故事是关于一段录音，它捕捉到了今天节目所讨论的——那种低沉的威胁感。这段录音是一位试图抓到骚扰她的男子的女性秘密录制的。在此提醒听众，这个故事涉及性骚扰，所以会有些性内容。
One thing I have to say that's interesting about this recording and the man's behavior in it is how understated it is. He doesn't raise his voice. He doesn't overtly threaten, but he just gets his point across. Also interesting, the woman who made the recording-- her name is Khristen Sellers. Years later, today, when she hears this recording, she hears it very differently than she did at the time. It raises a whole set of questions she didn't think about much back then. Reporter Jessica Lussenhop met Khristen years ago putting together a story for the BBC. Here's Jessica.
关于这段录音以及那名男子的行为，有一点很有趣，那就是他的表达非常含蓄。他没有提高嗓门，也没有公开威胁，但他却准确地表达了他的意思。还有一点很有趣，录制这段录音的女性，她的名字叫克莉丝汀·塞勒斯。多年后的今天，当她再听这段录音时，感受与当时截然不同。它引发了一系列她当年没怎么考虑过的问题。记者杰西卡·卢森霍普几年前在为英国广播公司撰写报道时遇到了克莉丝汀。下面是杰西卡。
The recording is just 10 minutes long. The man Khristen was trying to record was her home inspector. This is back in 2012. At the time, she didn't have a cell phone, so she borrowed one from her friend.
这段录音只有10分钟。克莉丝汀试图录音的对象是她的房屋检查员。那是2012年的事了。当时她没有手机，所以借了朋友的手机。
Can you just sort of explain how you made this recording in the first place?
你能简单解释一下你最初是怎么录下这段录音的吗？
OK. I had on some around the house cleanup clothing, like baggy clothing. So I had a phone, and I took the phone, and I put it in my shirt. Put it in, I think, it was my bra strap or something, sitting some type of way odd.
好的。我当时穿着打扫屋子用的衣服，比如宽松的衣服。我拿了手机，把它塞进衬衫里。把它塞进……我想是文胸肩带还是什么地方，总之是塞在一个很奇怪的位置。
Because of the phone under the shirt secured by a bra strap, the recording is hard to hear. Hiding the phone there, Khristen's nervous. She gives herself a task-- raking the yard-- as she waits for Eric Pender to pull up. He is who she wants to record.
由于手机压在衬衫里并用文胸肩带固定，录音听起来很困难。把手机藏在那里，克莉丝汀很紧张。她给了自己一个任务——耙院子里的草——等待埃里克·彭德到来。他就是她想录音的目标。
She's kind of afraid of him, but she's focused on all the things anyone making this kind of recording might be. She wants to stay calm, not look suspicious, act natural. And most importantly, she wants to get audio of Eric Pender harassing her so she has undeniable proof. Eric Pender's red truck pulls up and parks on the street.
她其实有点怕他，但她专注于任何做这种录音的人都会关注的事情。她想保持冷静，看起来不那么可疑，举止自然。最重要的是，她想录下埃里克·彭德骚扰她的音频，作为不可辩驳的证据。埃里克·彭德的红色卡车开过来，停在了街上。
There was a long driveway. So I'm in a wooded area, ain't no whole bunch of houses near me or nothing, and he was walking up. But I was still raking, doing both. And he was coming up towards me, and I was kind of trying to turn the other way. That's when he kind of got real close, and he was like, I'm--
那是一条很长的车道。我当时在树林边，附近根本没什么人家，他走过来。我一边耙草一边做别的事。他朝我走过来，我当时试图转过身去。就在那时，他靠得非常近，他说，我——
You know, Ms. Sellers, you need to be careful of who you talk to. I'm not worried about me.
你知道，塞勒斯女士，你说话得小心点，别什么人都聊。我不担心我自己。
Be careful who you talk to. I'm not worried about me.
说话得小心点。我不担心我自己。
Just somebody you think that you can trust, and I'm just letting you know you probably can't trust them.
别什么人都以为你可以信任，我只是告诉你，你可能根本不能信任他们。
But if there's somebody you think you can trust, then I'm just letting you know you probably can't trust them.
如果有人你以为可以信任，那我只是告诉你，你可能根本不能信任他们。
He basically was saying I need to watch what I'm saying to people and how I'm talking to them, and I'm like, what am I saying to people? I'm trying to put the face on of I'm not saying nothing to nobody. What are you talking about?
他基本上是在说我需要注意跟人说话的内容和方式，我就想，我跟谁说什么了？我正努力表现得好像我什么都没跟任何人说。你在说什么？
How far away is he from you when he's--
当你录音的时候，他离你有多远？
Probably like how me and her is right now.
大概就像我和她现在这样的距离。
My producer, Robyn-- she's about two feet away. This recording is the fourth time Khristen had spoken to Eric Pender ever.
我的制作人罗宾——她离我大概两英尺远。这段录音是克莉丝汀和埃里克·彭德总共进行的第四次对话。
All right, I already know how people use lies. I ain't-- look, you need to-- look, if you think-- [INAUDIBLE].
好了，我早就知道人们怎么利用谎言。我不——听着，你需要——听着，如果你认为——[听不清]。
I'm super nervous, and nothing-- I'm so nervous at that point I was shaking, and I couldn't believe he didn't see it. It was like a tremble in me that I just was trying to hold on to the rake as hard as I could so that he wouldn't see the tremble in me. You know what I mean?
我当时超级紧张，什么都不——那一刻我太紧张了，浑身发抖，我简直不敢相信他没看见。我感觉身体在颤抖，我只能死死抓住耙子，免得让他看出我在发抖。你明白我的意思吗？
Were you making eye contact with him?
你和他有眼神接触吗？
I really was like down to the rake, down to the rake. It was like, if I was somebody else, the way I was raking in the same spot, I would have been like, what is she doing? But I was still in the same spot because I was scared to move. I was just nervous.
我真的就是一直盯着耙子看。如果换成别人，看到我一直在同一个地方耙草，肯定会问，她在那儿干嘛呢？但我还是待在原地，因为我不敢动。我太紧张了。
The house Eric Pender was coming to inspect wasn't Khristen's yet. It was a house she was hoping to move into with her three kids. The only thing she needed to move in was his signature on a form.
埃里克·彭德要去检查的房子还不是克莉丝汀的。那是她希望带着三个孩子搬进去的房子。搬进去唯一需要的就是他在表格上签字。
She needs this house. Just two weeks earlier, Khristen was staying at her mom's, just home from a prison stint. She served six months for a probation violation. She was looking for a house for her and her kids. If you needed a Section 8 voucher in Laurinburg, a small town in a rural area of North Carolina, one of the only places to go was a nonprofit called Four-County Community Services.
她需要这栋房子。就在两周前，克莉丝汀刚从监狱服刑回来，一直住在她妈妈家。她因为违反缓刑规定服刑了六个月。她在为自己和孩子们寻找住所。如果你在北卡罗来纳州一个农村小镇劳林堡需要Section 8租房券，唯一的去处就是一家叫“四县社区服务”的非营利组织。
The problem was the only house they were willing to give her was a house no one else seemed to want. Khristen was like, OK. I'm not picky.
问题是他们愿意给她的那栋房子，似乎没人想要。克莉丝汀心想，好吧，我不挑剔。
They had a house, and they said that house in particular was abandoned. And if I was to clean that house out, that I would go ahead and be able to move in the house, and wouldn't have to pay a deposit. They actually called the landlord, and they will pay the first month's rent. I think that's how it went, yeah.
他们有栋房子，说那栋房子是空置的。如果我能把那栋房子打扫干净，我就能搬进去，而且不需要付押金。他们实际上联系了房东，他们会付第一个月的房租。我想大概就是这么回事。
So if she cleaned the house, it'd be hers, but cleaning the house, she'd come to learn, was a big project. It was a three bedroom house with a dining room and den, and all the rooms were filled with junk. It smelled awful. There were roaches, lots of poop.
如果她打扫干净，房子就是她的了。但她后来发现，打扫这栋房子是一项大工程。那是一栋带餐厅和书房的三居室，所有房间都堆满了垃圾。闻起来臭气熏天。到处都是蟑螂，还有很多粪便。
The neighbors had told me that's why it was so many feces and stuff in the house, because they had left the dog. And then finally, I guess, the dog either died or left, and they got it out. I don't know. But by the time I got there, I just was there with the leftover-- the house being full of clothing and food in the cabinets. It was all this stuff. It was just horrible.
邻居告诉我，房子里之所以有那么多粪便，是因为之前的人留下了狗。最后，我猜那狗要么死了要么跑了，他们才把狗带走。我不知道。但等我到那儿的时候，屋子里剩下的就是满屋子的衣服和柜子里的食物。简直太可怕了。
She cleaned and cleaned. She had a list of tasks that she'd been given from the nonprofit.
她不停地打扫。非营利组织给了她一份任务清单。
It took weeks, like maybe two weeks or so, three weeks, maybe even more than that. I can't even really remember remember. I just remember going a lot of times doing it. Well, I called down there, and they sent the inspector out. I thought I had everything done that was my duty to do.
花了几个星期，可能两三周吧，甚至更久。我都记不清了。我只记得去了很多次才干完。好了，我打电话过去，他们派了检查员来。我以为我已经完成了我该做的一切职责。
Eric Pender showed up. He was the housing inspector for Four-County. He's a tall man, older, light skinned black man with a taste for cowboy boots and belts, khakis. Pender was there to review Khristen's work. If she passed his inspection, she'd get approved to move in.
埃里克·彭德出现了。他是“四县”的房屋检查员。他个子很高，是个上了年纪的浅肤色黑人，喜欢穿牛仔靴、系腰带、穿卡其裤。彭德来审查克莉丝汀的工作。如果她通过了他的检查，她就能获准入住。
Anyway, he was like, you need to have a man to help you. Why you don't have a boyfriend? And all this. And I'm like, I don't have one because I'm just coming out from prison. I'm trying to get on my feet for my kids. I'm trying to explain to him, and he was like, but if you had a man here, a man could get this stuff done. And I'm like, I did it. What are you asking me to do?
总之，他说，你需要个男人帮你。为什么你没有男朋友？诸如此类的。我说，我没有是因为我刚从监狱出来，我正试图为了孩子站稳脚跟。我试图向他解释，但他又说，但如果你这儿有个男人，男人就能把这些事做完。我说，我一个人做完了啊。你到底想让我干什么？
This talk of men quickly turned explicit. Khristen said he asked her about her sex life, if she performed oral sex before.
这些关于男人的话题很快变得露骨起来。克莉丝汀说他问起她的性生活，问她以前有没有过口交。
And I was like, what? I was totally thrown. And he was like, because you have had men to take you out to dinner and stuff. And then I had told him, yeah, I have. And he was like, well, you having people take you out to dinner. That's what they were paying you for. They were paying you for sex. He said, let's say your rent's $600 times 12 months.
我当时就想，什么？我彻底惊呆了。他说，因为肯定有男人带你出去吃饭之类的。我告诉他，是的，确实有过。他说，好吧，你让人家带你出去吃饭。他们带你吃饭其实是在付钱。他们是在付钱买性。他说，假设你的房租是600美元，乘以12个月。
Her rent was $600 a month. So to be clear, he was laying out her exact situation. He proposed sex with him as a kind of home insurance policy that Pender valued at over a year's worth of rent.
她的房租是每月600美元。所以说清楚点，他是在阐述她的具体处境。他提议与他发生关系，作为一种房屋保险政策，彭德给出的价值超过了一年的房租。
And he was like, that's way over $6,000. My signature is over $6,000. So you'll be having sex for-- basically, he mapped it out just like that.
他说，那远不止6000美元。我的签字价值超过6000美元。所以你要为这——他基本上就是这么计算的。
Did he even acknowledge that you had cleaned the whole house?
他有没有承认你已经把整栋房子清理干净了？
He didn't. He didn't want to. He wanted to let me know that I still had stuff to do.
他没有。他不想承认。他想让我知道我还有很多事要做。
I'm stuck, because I know I'm in here with this man. And I'm like, he can sign this paper, and he can not sign this paper. He can say whatever, and my word against him is what? So at this time, I'm like, what do I do? I just don't know. So I just knew to try to keep a distance between me and him as much as I could.
我被困住了，因为我知道我正跟这个男人待在里面。我想，他既可以签这张纸，也可以不签。他可以胡说八道，而我的一面之词又能算什么呢？所以我当时就想，我该怎么办？我完全不知道。所以我只能想办法尽量和他保持距离。
Pender toured the house with Khristen following behind him. He starts pointing to stuff that wasn't Khristen's responsibility to clean up, that wasn't on the list that the nonprofit gave her-- broken mirrors, a broken toilet.
彭德参观房子，克莉丝汀跟在后面。他开始指出那些不是克莉丝汀负责清理的东西，那些根本不在非营利组织给她的清单上的东西——破碎的镜子、坏掉的马桶。
That's where he was telling me the toilet needed fixing, and he kind of pulled me by the hip in the bathroom. And he pulled himself out in front of me.
就在那里，他跟我说马桶需要修理，然后他在浴室里拉住了我的臀部。然后他在我面前露出了他的生殖器。
Wait, what?
等等，什么？
Yeah, he pulled himself out, and I looked down. And I looked up, and I kind of like-- I need to get out-- find a way out. So I kind of got out of the bathroom.
是的，他把自己露了出来，我低头看了看，又抬头看了看，我当时就想——我得出去——得找条出路。所以我从浴室退了出来。
And he's blocking you. He's in the bathroom door.
他把你堵住了。他在浴室门口。
Yeah, he's blocking me.
对，他堵着门。
And you're in the bathroom and can't get out.
你在浴室里，出不来。
Mhm, yeah.
嗯，是的。
And he exposes himself to you.
他向你暴露了自己。
Definitely. And he was like, you know what to do. You know what I'm saying? You know if you want this house, you know what you got to do. That's what he was saying at that point.
确实。他说，你知道该怎么做。你明白我的意思吗？你知道如果你想要这栋房子，你就知道你该怎么做。他当时就是这么说的。
She says the only thing she was sure of was that there was no way she was going to do what he wanted ever. She managed to push past him, gets him to leave. He doesn't sign the form. It was overwhelming.
她说她唯一确定的是，无论如何她绝不可能做他想让她做的事。她最终推开他冲了出去，让他离开。他没有签那份表。这太让人难以承受了。
I broke down, because I felt like, when you're in situations like I was in, you feel kind of like you've got low self-esteem already. And so dealing with that situation is just kind of like-- you just feel like that's what-- he looks at you like-- is that how men look at you? And so it's just like I'm going to say whatever to her because she is who she is.
我崩溃了，因为我感觉，当你像我当时那样处于那种境地时，你本身就会感到自卑。经历那种事情让你觉得——他那样看你——男人就是那样看你的吗？所以我只能说，他想说什么就说吧，因为我就是这样的人。
Khristen did not go to the police. She thought it was her word against his and that, because of her record, she wouldn't be believed. She thought she needed to bolster her claim in some way, collect some evidence or something. She called a private investigator, wondering if they could surveil him, but they were too expensive. The private investigator she talked to gave her this tip. North Carolina is a one-party consent state, meaning it was legal for Khristen to record him, try to get proof without his permission.
克莉丝汀没有报警。她以为只有她的一面之词，而且因为她的前科，没人会相信她。她以为自己需要用某种方式来加强申诉，收集一些证据之类的。她给私家侦探打了电话，想知道他们能不能监控他，但费用太贵了。和她交谈的私家侦探给了她一个建议。北卡罗来纳州是一方同意即可录音的州，意味着克莉丝汀在未经彭德允许的情况下录音是合法的，可以尝试获取证据。
But your friends know enough to hurt you.
但你的朋友们知道得足以伤害你。
Yeah.
是啊。
You see what I'm saying? They know--
你知道我的意思吗？他们知道——
Which brings us back to the recording Khristen made on that Sunday in April back in 2012. Pender is coming back ostensibly to inspect the house. He still hasn't signed the form she needs to move in. Remember, Khristen is trying to record Pender propositioning her, but when he walks up, he's not doing that. He starts talking about his job at the housing office, how he is in charge of handling complaints.
这就回到了克莉丝汀在2012年4月那个周日录下的录音。彭德回来表面上是为了检查房子。他还是没签她搬进去需要的表格。记住，克莉丝汀在试图录下彭德向她求欢的过程，但当他走过来时，他没那么做。他开始谈论他在住房办公室的工作，谈论他如何负责处理投诉。
Any time I deal with a complaint, the complaints come to me all the time.
每当我处理投诉时，投诉总是不断找上我。
He says, any time I deal with a complaint-- he's talking to you about a complaint. Do you know what he's talking about?
他说，每当我处理投诉——他在跟你谈投诉的事。你知道他在说什么吗？
See, that's what he was saying. He was saying that somebody told his boss that I said that he was making advances and bothering me.
看，这就是他在说的。他是说有人告诉他老板，我说他对我动手动脚，还在骚扰我。
Which she hadn't. She'd only told a few people and that private investigator about Pender. Confused, Khristen tries to play it off.
而她根本没说过。她只告诉了几个人和那个私家侦探关于彭德的事。克莉丝汀感到困惑，试图敷衍过去。
You sure?
你确定？
I'm positive. You want to [BLEEP] me?
我很确定。你想[消音]我吗？
I just can't see that now.
我现在真看不出来。
Just don't stir it up. Don't say nothing. Now, I'm just telling you when somebody's in your business. The sum of all this for Khristen-- she's realizing that telling her housing office about Pender, filing an actual complaint is out of the question.
别去搅混水。什么都别说。我只是告诉你什么时候有人在打你的主意。对克莉丝汀来说，所有这一切总结起来就是——她意识到把彭德的情况告诉她的住房办公室，提出正式投诉是不可能的。
Instead of calling me, they call him and tell him everything instead of calling me, saying, is this happening to you? So at that point, you know that nobody on your side.
他们不给我打电话，反而直接打给他，把一切都告诉他，而不是打电话问我，‘这真的发生了吗？’所以在那一点上，你就知道根本没人站在你这边。
Now, the people that's close to you know that you've got a task ahead of you. I don't see them.
现在，你身边亲近的人都知道你面前有个任务。我没看见他们。
It's a weird recording because Eric Pender says things that sound simultaneously like a threat and like they could be the advice of someone who's protective and caring. Pender had what Khristen considered a supreme confidence, where he could finesse words, make insults sound flowery and innocent.
这段录音很诡异，因为埃里克·彭德说的话听起来既像威胁，又像是一个有保护欲和关怀之人的建议。彭德有一种克莉丝汀认为至高无上的自信，他能巧妙地运用言辞，让侮辱听起来花哨而无辜。
It's like, to me, he was just trying to make me his friend. And I was trying to keep myself afloat in the conversation while I was feeling like I was drowning at the same time.
对我来说，他就像是在试图让我成为他的朋友。我试图在谈话中维持现状，同时又感觉自己快要窒息。
For example, as she's raking, Pender starts lecturing her about her kids.
例如，当她耙草时，彭德开始教导她关于她孩子的事。
You really should've had your kids over here, too.
你真的应该把孩子们也带到这儿来。
Yeah. No, I mean, but they're not here. They don't be here none.
是啊。没，我是说，他们不在这儿。他们根本不来这儿。
Well, I know, but I'm just saying, if they were here, you should have them here raking in this yard. And you've got a son, right?
好吧，我知道，但我只是说，如果他们在这儿，你应该让他们在这儿帮着耙草。你有儿子吧，对吧？
Mhm.
嗯。
This is part of being a man. When I was coming up, my mama-- that's how I learned to work in my yard. It's a part of that growing up process. I don't where your daddy fits in this life, but you've got to give him these two-- look, you tell what's-his-name, little man, say look, you're going to be a man one day. You're going to need to know how to change a tire. You're going to need to know how to light the grill. You're going to need to know how to take care of this yard.
这是做男人的一部分。我小时候，我妈妈——我就是这么学会帮家里干活的。这是成长过程的一部分。我不知道你爸爸在这个生命中扮演什么角色，但你得把这交给他们——你看，你告诉那个谁，小伙子，说你看，你将来有一天要成为男人。你需要学会怎么换轮胎。你需要学会怎么用烤炉。你需要学会怎么照顾这个院子。
All Khristen can think is this is not what she was hoping to get recorded.
克莉丝汀能想到的只有，这不是她希望能录到的内容。
I didn't think none of this was going to work, because I was-- I'm used to him coming, saying, what's up [BLEEP]. You going to have sex. You're going to do this, being very blunt on what he want, and why he want it, and when I'm going to do it, and what I get for doing it. When I'm recording something, it's like--
我以为这些都不会奏效，因为我——我习惯了他过来就说，‘嘿，[消音]。你要来一发吗？你要做这个。’非常直截了当，明确他想要什么，为什么要，我什么时候做，做了能得到什么。当我在录音时，这感觉就像是——
It's all over.
完全不是那么回事。
--all over the place. So I'm like, oh, this is not going to work. So that's how I felt at that point.
——乱七八糟的。所以我心想，哦，这录音不会起作用了。我当时就是这么想的。
But also, all that advice about how she should raise her kids--
但也包括那些关于她该如何教育孩子的建议——
He's arrogant, and he's like I'm beneath. In his mind, he could say what he want to say to me, no matter who's involved. You're beneath me, so I know how to raise your children. Now, you're beneath me, so I know how to get you in this house. And you're beneath me, so I can help you. Everything was talking down, or making me feel like I'm not enough, or I'm not a good enough mom. Everything was to try to belittle me into nothing.
他很傲慢，就像我低人一等。在他心中，他想对我说什么就说什么，不管是谁卷入其中。你低我一等，所以我知道怎么教育你的孩子。既然你低我一等，我就知道怎么让你住进这房子。你低我一等，所以能帮你的只有我。所有的一切都是在居高临下，或者让我觉得自己不够好，或者我不是个好母亲。一切都是为了试图贬低我，把我变得一无是处。
Pender keeps talking, but not about home inspection. He still doesn't explicitly proposition Khristen, like the first time that they met. He's suggestive, though. He mentions for no apparent reason how women need to stop acting like they don't know how they got pregnant.
彭德一直在说，但不是关于房屋检查的事。他还是没有像他们第一次见面那样直白地提出交易。不过他暗示了。他无缘无故地提到女人为什么需要停止假装不知道自己是怎么怀孕的。
[INAUDIBLE] get mad. Y'all know where babies come from. You [BLEEP], you get pregnant. Damn, I mean, don't be mad at the world.
[听不清]别生气。你们都知道孩子是怎么来的。你们[消音]，就会怀孕。该死，我是说，别跟全世界过不去。
He goes further. He reminds Khristen how he came by her house and, quote, "asked her for some."
他更进一步。他提醒克莉丝汀他是怎么来到她家，“向她索要一些”。
And seeing how I came by and asked you for some anyway. I said, well, damn, maybe-- and then I start thinking-- I say, well--
而且鉴于我来过并且还是向你索要了一些。我说，该死，也许——然后我就开始想——我说，好吧——
Well, maybe it's--
好吧，也许是因为——
It's maybe because you like women, and maybe I should never even approach you.
也许是因为你喜欢女人，也许我甚至根本不该靠近你。
I do not like no women, Mr. Pender.
我不喜欢女人，彭德先生。
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know what you like.
我不知道。我不知道。我不知道你喜欢什么。
Oh--
哦——
This is my first-- second time even seeing you, so--
这是我第一次——第二次见到你，所以——
What if I was gay? You know what I'm saying? So what? Why would you use that against me? You know what I'm saying?
如果我是同性恋又怎样？你知道我的意思吗？那又怎样？为什么要用那个来对付我？你明白吗？
But he would do that. Anything that he felt could be a target to hit you in a way to make you feel like I've got to prove him I'm not this. Then he would use that.
但他就是会那样做。任何他觉得可以作为打击目标，让你觉得我必须向他证明我不是那样的人，他都会利用。
Did you feel like he was trying to make you angry?
你觉得他是想让你生气吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Right, that's--
对，那是——
Yeah, I did. I felt like he was trying to make me give in to say, no, I'm not like that. I'll do it to prove it or something.
是的，我是这么觉得。我觉得他想让我屈服，想让我说，‘不，我不是那样的人。’我会为了证明这一点而妥协之类的。
He hints at making a deal with her to help her with her housing, but doesn't spell out what she'd have to do in that deal. Khristen keeps recording. He reminds her that he has a lot of authority and can help her.
他暗示要和她达成协议以帮助她的住房，但没有明说她必须在协议中做什么。克莉丝汀继续录音。他提醒她，他拥有很大的权力，可以帮助她。
I do have some discrepancy on how I enforce the rules. It may be a situation-- your power might be off. You got 48 hours sometimes with your power off. I'm going to come--
对于如何执行规则，我确实有一些分歧。可能是这种情况——你的电可能停了。有时停电后你有48小时。我会来的——
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
I'm going to come back in three days, instead of two. That's going to be your extra day to get your power back on, so forth and so on. I want--
我会三天后再来，而不是两天。那会是你恢复供电的额外时间，诸如此类。我想——
That's back to what I know. The previous conversations, when he do ask for sex and all that, that's how he get to that-- is I'm helping you, so let me tell you what you got to do to get that help. So that tone is what I was used to, so when he got to that calm place, I'm like, here you go. Finna try to make me feel like he's helping me, because if I have sex, I have somewhere to stay for having sex forever.
那又回到我所知道的了。之前的对话里，当他要求性交易时，他就是通过这种方式——我是在帮你，所以让我告诉你你得做什么才能得到帮助。所以我对那种语气很熟悉，当他变得平和时，我就想，来了。他试图让我觉得他在帮我，因为如果我和他发生关系，我就能因为发生关系而永远有地方住。
And he's getting ready to go on today. I want you to do such and such. I did. At that point, I really knew, OK, it's coming.
他准备今天就开始了。我要你做这个做那个。我就做了。在那一刻，我确实知道，好吧，它来了。
But it doesn't come. Pender instead brings up the most on topic housing inspection related subject of his visit-- the barn. There's this little barn-type shed in Khristen's backyard. It's filled with garbage, and Khristen had put snake repellent around the outside of it to keep snakes, if there were any, trapped inside. Pender says, I'd get that barn cleaned out.
但他没那样。彭德反而提起了他这次访问中最相关的问题——谷仓。克莉丝汀后院有个小谷仓式的棚子。里面堆满了垃圾，克莉丝汀在外面围了一圈蛇药，如果有蛇的话，就把它们关在里面。彭德说，我会把那个谷仓清理干净的。
Get this barn cleaned out. I'm going to say something.
把这个谷仓清理干净。我得说点什么。
Now, he said that he was--
现在，他说他——
Get it clean up because--
把它清理干净，因为——
The guy that was here, he was paying them.
那个在那儿的人，他付钱给他们。
All this--
所有这些——
Pender starts listing all the things she could use the barn for-- card games, an escape from the kids. He's suddenly singly focused on the potential greatness of a rundown barn.
彭德开始列举她可以用谷仓做的所有事情——打牌，从孩子身边逃离。他突然专注于一个破旧谷仓的潜在伟大之处。
You could keep stuff in that barn. You and your friends want to have a card game away from the kids [INAUDIBLE] just get one [INAUDIBLE].
你可以把东西保存在那个谷仓里。你和你的朋友想在远离孩子的地方玩纸牌游戏[听不清]只要搞定一个[听不清]。
Mhm. Yeah, because you can go in the barn, and you see how the window in the barn-- and say, we can go in the barn. And you can have this here. It was just like, the more he was describing, the closer he was trying to get to the barn. He was trying to find a way to get me there, and mind you, we're outside. So I guess him trying to do anything-- that would probably be the best place for him.
嗯。是的，因为你可以去谷仓里，你看看谷仓里的窗户——然后说，我们可以去谷仓里。你可以把这个放在那儿。就像这样，他描述得越多，他就越想靠近谷仓。他试图找办法把我引到那儿，别忘了，我们在外面。所以我猜他想做什么的话——那对他来说可能是最好的地方。
Pender keeps insisting she go in the barn with him. Khristen keeps avoiding it. She won't go. She finally says, if I see a snake in there, I'm going to pass out and die.
彭德一直坚持让她跟他一起进谷仓。克莉丝汀一直回避。她不进去。她最终说，如果我在里面看到蛇，我会昏死过去的。
And they met at [INAUDIBLE] so he mailing him a check.
他们见面时[听不清]，所以他寄给他一张支票。
[INAUDIBLE]. Yeah, I would certainly take-- even if you had to do it, I would take these two bags at a time.
[听不清]。是的，我肯定会——即使你不得不做，我也会一次拿两个袋子。
He mailing a check for them today. I'm not going in with the snake. I'm going to passed out die. I felt like, if I would've went in that barn, he definitely-- it would have been OK for him in his mind that she's saying OK. And I knew I wasn't going in there, so.
他今天给他们寄了支票。我不进去看蛇。我会昏过去死掉的。我觉得，如果我进了那个谷仓，他肯定——在他心里，她进来了就意味着同意了。我知道我不会进去的，所以。
It seems to work. Pender backs off slowly. They have one last back and forth. He starts to walk away, says, all right then, we straight.
这似乎奏效了。彭德慢慢退后。他们最后做了一次往返谈话。他开始走开，说，好吧，那我们就两清了。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
All right, well, we straight.
好的，好吧，我们两清了。
Finally, he says the most damning thing he's said in the whole recording.
最后，他说出了他在整个录音中最恶毒的话。
Well--
好吧——
Well, we almost straight. You'll take care of me later on.
好吧，我们差不多两清了。你以后会照顾我的。
Just take it and rake it.
拿着它，耙好它。
Khristen stopped recording. She worried immediately that what she had recorded wasn't enough, and if it wasn't, that she was stuck right where she started-- her house hanging in the lurch. She felt desperate.
克莉丝汀停止了录音。她立即担心她录下来的东西不够，如果不够，她就会像最初一样被困住——她的房子悬而未决。她感到绝望。
How is this going to be over? When it's going to be over? Him saying I still got to take care of him-- it was just like, so this ain't going to be over until I do it. In his head, it's-- that's what it is. Until I have sex with him, this isn't over. It's not over.
这怎么才能结束呢？什么时候才能结束？他说我以后还得照顾他——这就像是，所以除非我做了，否则这事没完。在他脑子里，事实就是这样。除非我跟他发生关系，否则这事没完。这没完。
And in my mind, I knew that he had come to expect every year-- every year. And him having to expect every year, that means I had to have some kind of a sexual thing with him for him to approve it every year. I just was praying that that recording was enough proof that he's been doing it. So I just didn't know if I had enough proof.
在我脑子里，我知道他期望每年——每年。而他每年都有所期望，意味着我每年都得和他发生某种性关系，他才会每年批准。我只是祈祷那段录音足以证明他一直在这样做。所以我只是不知道我的证据够不够。
This recording kicked off a pretty remarkable series of events. Khristen used it to file a criminal charge against Eric Pender. He was convicted of simple assault, but appealed and got the case dropped. She also played the recording for a young lawyer, who didn't even have an office yet or know for sure if what Khristen was describing was illegal, but he listened to the tape, believed her, and took the case. Khristen's lawyer filed a civil suit, and a local paper ran a story about it.
这段录音开启了一系列相当引人注目的事件。克莉丝汀用它对埃里克·彭德提起了刑事诉讼。他被判轻微攻击罪，但上诉后案件被撤销。她还给一位年轻律师播放了这段录音，他甚至还没开办公室，也不知道克莉丝汀描述的情况是否违法，但他听了录音，相信了她，并接手了案子。克莉丝汀的律师提起了民事诉讼，当地报纸报道了这件事。
More and more women started coming forward with stories about Eric Pender and Pender's boss, John Wesley, who was also asking for sex in exchange for vouchers. The case grew from three women to eight, and then to 16. Six of the women went along with the men's sexual demands. One of them lost her housing anyway.
越来越多的女性开始站出来讲述关于埃里克·彭德和彭德的老板约翰·韦斯利的遭遇，后者也要求以性作为交换条件来提供租房券。案件从三名女性发展到八名，然后到十六名。其中六名女性顺从了男性的性要求。即便如此，其中一人还是失去了住房。
The lawsuit ran on for years, which became its own form of punishment for Khristen, because Eric Pender was still her home inspector. He continued working for them. At one point, he tried to cancel Khristen's voucher. Her lawyers blocked it.
诉讼持续了多年，这成了对克莉丝汀的一种惩罚，因为埃里克·彭德仍然是她的房屋检查员。他继续为他们工作。有一次，他试图取消克莉丝汀的租房券。她的律师阻止了。
The case was moved from state to federal court. Department of Justice lawyers got involved. Khristen got called all the names-- liar, felon, opportunist. Once, in a grocery store, a woman Khristen barely knew approached her.
案件从州法院移交到了联邦法院。司法部的律师介入了。克莉丝汀被冠以各种骂名——骗子、罪犯、投机分子。有一次，在一家杂货店，一个克莉丝汀几乎不认识的女人接近她。
She really felt adamant on telling me you're messing this up. You're messing up how we get our vouchers. And that's--
她真的很坚持告诉我，你把事情搞砸了。你把我们拿租房券的事搞砸了。那就是——
She was saying we-- like not just me, a bunch of us.
她说我们——不仅仅是我，还有我们很多人。
Yeah, so that's when I kind of understood-- when she said this to me, it just kind of hit me on how they were able to do it for so long, how he was so confident, because look at how this woman feel.
是的，所以当我意识到——当她对我说这些话时，它触动了我，让他们能够得逞这么久，他为什么如此自信，因为看看这个女人的感受。
There aren't any good numbers on how common sexual harassment is in housing situations. No one seems to be tracking it. In July of 2015, three years after Khristen made the recording, the federal lawsuit ended. Four-County settled with the Department of Justice. Pender and Wesley were banned from working in Section 8, or renting or managing any property permanently. Neither admitted to any wrongdoing. Both denied all the allegations against them.
关于住房状况中的性骚扰有多普遍，目前还没有好的数据。似乎没人追踪这件事。2015年7月，也就是克莉丝汀录音三年后，联邦诉讼结束了。“四县”与司法部达成了和解。彭德和韦斯利被永久禁止在Section 8工作，或出租或管理任何房产。两人均未承认有任何不当行为。两人都否认了所有针对他们的指控。
I reached out to Pender and Wesley for this story. Wesley didn't call me back. I called Pender's lawyer, tried previous addresses, called old numbers, and his ex-wife. No one knew where he was. Four-County didn't respond either. They've changed their name since.
我就这个故事联系了彭德和韦斯利。韦斯利没给我回电话。我给彭德的律师打了电话，尝试了以前的地址，拨打了旧号码，还联系了他的前妻。没人知道他在哪儿。四县公司也没回应。从那以后他们改名了。
The women were awarded a $2.7 million settlement, the largest sexual harassment in housing settlement in US history at the time. Ultimately, the number of victims in the suit was 87. Khristen's recording was evidence of Pender's behavior, but now, years later, when she listens to it, she hears it very differently than she did at the time. What she hears is herself, who she is in that recording. She hears how small she becomes around him.
这些女性获得了270万美元的和解金，这是当时美国历史上住房性骚扰案件中最大的一笔和解金。最终，诉讼中的受害者人数为87人。克莉丝汀的录音是彭德行为的证据，但现在，多年后，当她再听时，她的感受与当时完全不同。她听到的就是她自己，她在录音中呈现的样子。她听到她在录音中变得多么渺小。
And she thought about the recording a lot. When I first called her in November to see if she might be willing to talk to me for this story, almost immediately she said, I'm glad you brought this up. She told me she'd never talked it through with anyone the way she's always wanted to. I visited Khristen in the house she moved to right after the case settled-- a three bedroom in Greensboro, where she lives with her two youngest kids. I played the recording for her. She hadn't heard it in years.
她经常想这段录音。去年11月，当我第一次打电话给她，看她是否愿意为这个故事和我交谈时，她几乎立即说，我很高兴你提起这件事。她告诉我，她从未像她一直想的那样，和任何人谈过这件事。我在案子和解后她搬进的房子里拜访了克莉丝汀——那是位于格林斯伯勒的一栋三居室，她和两个最小的孩子住在一起。我给她播放了那段录音。她好多年没听过了。
Even listening to it, I'm like, god, you could have said this. You could've said that. You could have did this. I beat myself up for some of that.
哪怕是听着它，我也想，天哪，你可以说这个啊。你可以说那个。你可以做这个。因为其中一些事，我一直在折磨自己。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, because I feel like I could have argued more or something. And I know that it did have a good outcome, but I just feel like, if I would've told him more-- and sometimes I wish I would have just told him off. I do beat myself up for some little things.
是的，因为我觉得我可以反驳更多，或者别的。我知道它确实有个好结果，但我只是觉得，如果我能多告诉他一些——有时我希望我当时就骂他一顿。我确实因为一些小事而自责。
The way she dealt with Eric Pender, she says, is something lots of women do with men, particularly men who have power over them. She laughs, deflects, pretends, tells half truths, demures, changes the subject, bites her tongue, smiles too much, agrees too much, hides her anger, hides all her emotions, buries her personality. It's so familiar I asked every woman I talked to in this lawsuit about it, and then nearly every woman in my life about it. As we talked, Khristen and I started calling it the tactic.
她说，她处理埃里克·彭德的方式，是很多女性在面对男性时会采取的方式，特别是面对对她们有权力的男性时。她大笑、转移话题、假装、说些半真半假的话、沉默、改变话题、咬住舌头、笑得太多、同意得太多、掩盖愤怒、隐藏所有情绪、埋葬自己的个性。这太熟悉了，我问过这起诉讼中我交谈过的每一位女性，后来又问过我生命中几乎每一位女性。在交谈中，克莉丝汀和我也开始称之为“战术”。
The tactic come in place when it's somebody who has control or somebody who I have to see on a regular basis and they're affecting my livelihood, because your like, my dream is on the other side of that person. You know what I'm saying? My livelihood is on the other side of this person. So if I try to tear this person down, then they can stop me from reaching that. You know what I'm saying?
当你面对一个控制你或者你必须经常见到、且影响你生计的人时，战术就会发挥作用，因为你会觉得，我的梦想就在那个人背后。你知道我的意思吗？我的生计就在那个人背后。所以如果我试图搞垮这个人，他们就能阻止我实现梦想。你知道我的意思吗？
When do you think you learned it? When do you think you-- what's the first memory you have of trying to use this as a strategy to get through a difficult situation?
你觉得你是什么时候学会这个的？你觉得你——你第一次记得试图用它作为策略去应付困难局面的记忆是什么？
I had a certain family member that would do things to hurt me, but I didn't want them to hurt me. So I knew I got to be in the same house with him for a certain period of time.
我有一个特定的家人，会做一些伤害我的事，但我不想让他们伤害我。所以我知道在一段时间内我必须和他待在同一栋房子里。
This family member abused Khristen both physically and sexually until she was about 12 years old. As a kid, she never told anybody.
这个家人对克莉丝汀进行了身体和性虐待，直到她大约12岁。作为孩子，她从没告诉过任何人。
Being in low income families, a lot of people shelter these things because it would cause more pain to the family. We already struggling. We already going through this. We already going through that, so why would I put more on the family? You know what I mean?
在低收入家庭里，很多人会掩盖这些事，因为它会给家庭带来更多痛苦。我们已经很挣扎了。我们已经经历了这个，经历那个，所以我为什么要给家里添乱？你明白吗？
Then you also have the fact that it's embarrassing. And what if don't nobody believe you? And now you got all those things. So it just seems better to shelter it.
然后你还要面对它很尴尬的事实。要是没人相信你怎么办？现在你又有了所有这些顾虑。所以掩盖它似乎更好。
She didn't start using these tactics with Eric Pender, and she didn't stop using them after him. In the years since the lawsuit, Khristen said she found herself in a job where, again, someone in a higher position than her started making sexually explicit comments to her. She was afraid to offend him, so she used the tactic, made up an excuse to redirect him. She told him, I'm not for you. I'm too crazy, and you should steer clear of me.
她并不是从埃里克·彭德开始使用这些战术的，也不是在他之后就停止使用的。诉讼后的几年里，克莉丝汀说她发现自己身处的一份工作中，再次有人地位比她高，开始对她发表性露骨的评论。她害怕冒犯他，所以她用了这个战术，编了个借口来转移他的注意力。她告诉他，我不是你的菜。我太疯狂了，你应该离我远点。
Not long after, Khristen says the guy walked right up behind her and grabbed her breast. Khristen quit that day, walked out, never went back. She told me, I can't file a federal lawsuit every time something like this happens to me.
没过多久，克莉丝汀说那家伙直接走到她背后，抓住了她的胸部。克莉丝汀那天就辞职了，走出去再也没回去。她告诉我，我不能每次遇到这种事就提一次联邦诉讼。
So like I said, Khristen's thought about the recording with Eric Pender and how she handled him in the recording a lot over the years. I asked her, after all this, if you could go back to when you first met Eric Pender, what do you wish you'd have said?
所以就像我说的，多年来，克莉丝汀经常想到和埃里克·彭德的那段录音，以及她在录音中是如何应付他的。我问她，经历了这一切后，如果你能回到刚见到埃里克·彭德的时候，你希望当时能说什么？
Oh yeah, now, on that note-- [LAUGHS] look, on that note, yeah, I just-- I wish I could have just looked at him and said, Mr. Pender, I'm not interested in you. I don't want you in no type of way, form, or fashion. I don't want to have no dinners with you for a voucher here, now, or forever more. I don't want no dinners with you, and I wish you would just stop asking me, because to me, I felt like he didn't think I could complete a sentence like that.
哦，是的，关于那点——[大笑]你看，关于那点，是的，我只是——我希望我能直接看着他说，彭德先生，我不对你感兴趣。我无论如何、以任何形式或方式都不想跟你扯上关系。我不想为了一个租房券而跟你吃任何晚餐，现在不想，将来更不想。我不想跟你吃晚餐，我希望你别再问了，因为对我来说，我觉得他没想到我能说出那样完整的句子。
And if I would have said it to him like that, maybe he would've been like, wow, whoa. She talk a little bit better than I thought. That would've been the best thing for me-- to be able to say it to him in a way where it's like, OK, you're not beneath me-- I mean, I'm not beneath you. We're eye to eye hear.
如果我那样对他说了，也许他会说，哇，哇。她说话比我想象的要好一点。那对我来说就是最好的事——能以一种平等的方式对他说，好吧，你并没有比我高人一等——我的意思是，我并不比你低人一等。我们是平等的。
Just the other day, Khristen told me she has a new tactic. She used it with a guy at her work who kept trying to tell her these sexual jokes. Khristen was not having it. In a roomful of people, with her boss watching, she tried her new move, and it worked. He backed off. She said to the guy, Google me, because I will record you.
就在前几天，克莉丝汀告诉我她有了一个新战术。她对工作里的一个家伙用了，那个人一直试图对她讲些性笑话。克莉丝汀没理他。在一个满是人的房间里，在老板的注视下，她试了她的新招，管用了。他退缩了。她对那家伙说，去搜搜我吧，因为我会录音的。
Jessica Lussenhop. Coming up, idle chit chat about a dog with an FBI agent can feel very threatening. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
杰西卡·卢森霍普。接下来，与FBI探员关于狗的闲聊可能会让人感到非常威胁。节目将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So it's March 2020, and in this week of schools closing, and people being quarantined, and the NBA, and Disneyland, and Broadway all shutting down, and still not enough tests out there to even begin to figure out how far coronavirus has spread, we have stories about moments when people feel a low hum of menace, a sense that things might get much worse. And it is not clear how much worse that means. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two-- Reality Show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。现在是2020年3月，在学校关闭、人们被隔离、NBA、迪士尼乐园和百老汇全部关门的一周里，依然没有足够的测试来判断新冠病毒传播到了多远，我们有一些故事，讲述了人们感受到那种低沉的威胁感，那种事情可能会变得更糟糕的感觉。而且不清楚“更糟糕”意味着什么程度。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕——真人秀。
So the first act of our program today was about a man who was breaking the rules. This act is about men enforcing rules. In this case, it's FBI agents. They're questioning a suspect. This interrogation happened in June 2017.
节目的第一部分是关于一个破坏规则的男人。这一部分是关于执法人员强制执行规则。在这种情况下，他们是FBI探员。他们正在审讯一名嫌疑人。这次审讯发生在2017年6月。
It's a real interrogation that happened. The suspect was an NSA contractor named Reality Winner. The FBI actually denied a request for the recording of this. They said it was not sufficiently in the public interest. Fortunately for us, theater director Tina Satter says she read the transcript of what was said and thought, this is a play, a thriller. This woman, alone in her house-- these men who arrive and question her. And Tina Satter put this on stage, more or less verbatim, with actors playing the agents and playing Reality Winner.
这是一次真实的审讯。嫌疑人是一名名叫雷亚蒂·温纳的NSA承包商。FBI实际上拒绝了对此录音的公开请求。他们说这不符合公共利益。幸运的是，戏剧导演蒂娜·萨特说她读了审讯记录，心想，这是一部戏，是一部惊悚片。这个女人独自在家里——这些男人到来并盘问她。蒂娜·萨特把这个搬上了舞台，几乎逐字逐句，演员们饰演探员和雷亚蒂·温纳。
Even the most casual small talk between them has this air to it. The entire thing on stage takes 70 minutes. We're going to play you an edited down excerpt. Emily Davis plays Reality Winner. TL Thompson and Pete Simpson play the special agents. Just so you know what's happening, when they get to a word, or phrase, or sentence that has been redacted in the original FBI transcript, they play this sound--
即使是他们之间最随意的闲聊也带有一种特殊的氛围。舞台上的整个过程需要70分钟。我们将为您播放一段删减版。艾米丽·戴维斯饰演雷亚蒂·温纳。TL·汤普森和皮特·辛普森饰演特别探员。为了让您了解情况，当他们读到原FBI记录中被删节的词汇、短语或句子时，他们会播放这个声音——
[RUMBLING]
[隆隆声]
So you can hear that sound now and then. The action starts outside Reality Winner's home in Augusta, Georgia, and then it moves inside. Here it is.
所以你偶尔能听到那个声音。行动开始于雷亚蒂·温纳位于乔治亚州奥古斯塔的家外，然后进入屋内。开始吧。
Let's show you who we are.
让你看看我们是谁。
Well, the reason we're here today is that we have a search warrant for your house.
嗯，我们今天到这儿来的原因是，我们要对你的房子执行搜查令。
OK.
好的。
All right, do you know what this might be about?
好了，你知道这可能是关于什么的吗？
I have no idea.
我不知道。
OK, this is about a possible mishandling of classified information.
好的，这关于可能泄露了机密信息。
Oh my goodness.
噢，天哪。
Mhm.
嗯。
OK.
好的。
So what we've got is-- again, got a warrant, and I'm happy to show it to you. What I'd like to do is sit down and talk you with-- talk with you about it, kind of go over what's going on. Talk to you, kind of get your side of it.
所以我们现在的做法是——再说一遍，我有搜查令，我很乐意给你看。我想坐下来跟你谈谈——和你谈谈这件事，回顾一下正在发生的事。和你谈谈，听听你的说法。
And of course, you-- completely voluntary to talk to me. We can talk here. Our office is about five minutes away. If you want to, we can talk there, if you'd rather. We can do either one. It makes no difference to me.
当然，你——和你谈完全是自愿的。我们可以在这里谈。我们的办公室就在五分钟路程的地方。如果你愿意，我们可以去那儿谈。两者都可以。对我来说没区别。
OK.
好的。
Do you have any pets?
你有宠物吗？
I do, I have two--
我有，我有两只——
Because you've been gone for a while.
因为你已经离开好一会儿了。
I do--
我有——
Do you live by yourself?
你是一个人住吗？
Yes.
是的。
What we're going to have to do is we're going to have to go into the house first to make sure it's safe.
我们现在得做的是，我们得先进入屋子确保它是安全的。
Absolutely.
当然。
We have a search warrant, so we're going to.
我们有搜查令，所以我们要进去。
Absolutely.
当然。
And what we'll do is we'll keep you out here until we do that, and once we secure it, well, then we'll kind of go from there, OK?
我们会把你留在外面直到我们做完，一旦确保安全，我们再从长计议，好吗？
Of course.
当然。
Is your dog friendly?
你的狗友好吗？
OK, so she does not like men.
好的，她不喜欢男人。
OK. So that's a problem.
好的。那是个问题。
However, and she might come towards you. She's never bitten anybody. She's not aggressive. She's just got a really good growl going. She'll probably just hide under my desk.
不过，她可能会朝你们走过来。她从没咬过任何人。她不凶。她只是会发出很大的咆哮声。她大概只会躲在我的桌子下面。
OK. Do we have a leash or something?
好的。有绳子之类的吗？
I have a leash. I can get her leashed up.
我有绳子。我可以带她套上绳子。
OK, so what we might want to do is maybe let you go in there with her. You're not to touch anything else.
好的，我们想做的是，也许让你进去陪她。你不能碰任何别的东西。
Yes, I can do that.
是的，我可以。
You're not to do anything else.
你不能做任何别的事。
Yeah, I can lead her straight to the backyard.
我可以带她直接去后院。
But the get the dog, and bring it out here.
先把狗带出来，带到这儿来。
Yes.
好的。
Are we cool?
我们说好了吗？
I understand
我明白了。
Because otherwise, if we're going to have a problem, we're not going to do that, so.
因为如果不这样，如果我们有麻烦的话，我们就不会这么做了，所以。
I understand.
我明白了。
OK.
好的。
House key?
房门钥匙？
House key.
房门钥匙。
OK. Are there any weapons in the car, in the house?
好的。车里或者屋里有武器吗？
In the house, yes.
屋子里有。
What do you have?
你有什么？
I have an AR-15.
我有一把AR-15。
Is it pink?
是粉色的吗？
It's pink. How did you know?
是粉色的。你怎么知道？
OK.
好的。
I have a Glock 9 under the bed.
床下有一把格洛克9毫米手枪。
OK.
好的。
And a 15 gauge.
还有一把15号口径的。
You sound like my house. OK.
听起来像我家。好的。
OK.
好的。
We're good, then.
那我们好了。
All right, just don't make any movements for anything [INAUDIBLE].
好的，别做任何动作去拿[听不清]。
Right, yeah. Yeah.
没问题。是的。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[重叠的声音]
Being kind of obvious.
表现得明显点。
We're all cool.
我们都很好。
Yeah. Yes, yes. And you won't even--
是的，是的。你甚至不会——
Then we'll get a water. We can get her a water--
然后我们去拿点水。我们可以给她拿点水——
You won't take your eyes off of me.
你离不开我的视线。
--and all that kind of stuff, but let's do that.
——诸如此类的，但让我们先做那个。
Of course.
当然。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手]
Come here, girl.
过来，女孩。
We're going to get the dog and bring it out here.
我们要去拿狗，把她带到这儿来。
Right here. I got her.
就在这儿。我抓着她。
All right, let me get your leash. Leash. I know. I know. There's people outside. I want to make this as easy for you guys as possible.
好的，让我拿你的绳子。绳子。我知道。我知道。外面有人。我想尽量让你们轻松一点。
OK, likewise. Just hopefully explain a couple things and--
好的，一样。希望解释几件事，然后——
[BARKING]
[狗叫声]
--to figure this all out, and wrap it up.
——搞清楚这一切，然后结束。
[BARKING]
[狗叫声]
How long you had your dog?
你的狗养多久了？
She's actually a foster. I'm rehabilitating her so that hopefully she can get adopted later on. She's actually a rescue. I think I got her in March.
她其实是寄养的。我正在帮她恢复，希望她以后能被收养。她其实是救援犬。我想我是三月份得到的她。
Yeah, my-- one of my dogs was a rescue, and when I got him, he wouldn't-- I was the only guy who could touch him. And this was probably all of three years. Anybody else came in the house, especially male, he'd pee all over the place, but I could touch him, and it was fine. But it was funny, I mean, he's seven years old now. He just comes up to everybody, licks his hand, and he's great. Whoever had him before was a real-- was a real piece of work. All right, so would you like to talk here or talk at the office?
是啊，我的——我的其中一只狗是救援犬，我得到他时，他是——我是唯一一个能摸他的男人。这大概持续了三年。任何其他人进屋，尤其是男性，他就会撒尿到处都是，但我能摸他，这没问题。但很有趣，他是说，他现在七岁了。他会跑到每个人面前，舔他们的手，他很棒。之前养他的人真是一个——真是个混蛋。好了，你是想在这谈还是去办公室谈？
Let's go ahead and talk here.
我们就在这谈吧。
OK.
好的。
You want to talk here?
你想在这儿谈？
Sure.
当然。
Let's-- I'm trying to think if we have any place in the house that we can kind of sit down that's private. Is there anything-- anything there in the house we can sit that's kind of away?
让我们——我在想我们在屋子里有没有什么地方可以坐下谈，要隐秘的。有什么——屋子里有什么地方我们可以坐，是偏僻点的？
Away?
偏僻？
How many rooms in--
有多少房间——
So it's a one bedroom. I do have a spare bedroom that I don't use that's empty. I don't like to go back there. I guess I don't have anything that's completely closed off, though.
是一居室。我有个空闲卧室不用，是空的。我不喜欢去那后面。不过，我想我没有什么完全封闭的空间。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
Except for that back room.
除了那个后屋。
That back room.
那个后屋。
Yeah.
对。
And it's completely empty.
它是完全空的吗？
Yeah, you'll go in there. There's one dog kennel cage. Other than that, I don't use the room.
是的，你们可以去那儿。里面有一个狗笼子。除此之外，我不使用那个房间。
OK, all right. You said you don't like to go in there?
好的，好的。你说你不喜欢去那里？
Yeah. It's just creepy. It's just weird. It's like an addition to the house that's behind the kitchen, and it's always dirty.
是的。那儿很阴森。很奇怪。那就像厨房后面的加建部分，而且一直很脏。
OK. We can talk back there if you're fine going back there. OK?
好的。如果你不介意去那儿的话，我们可以去那后面谈。好的吗？
Yeah, we can go back there. So I do have to ask, just however this goes-- and I'm not making any assumptions or anything like that, but is this going to be like a-- I brought my phone into the building type situation where I don't see my phone for three weeks, or?
是的，我们可以去那后面。所以我得问一下，不管结果如何——我不是在做任何假设之类的，但这会像那种——我把手机带进了大楼，三周内看不到手机的情况，或者？
So we'll go over the warrant itself.
我们会回顾搜查令本身。
OK.
好的。
So we do have a warrant for the phone, so.
所以我们确实有手机的搜查令，所以。
I'm not making any assumptions or anything like that, but I do teach yoga tomorrow, and the phone has music on it.
我不是在做假设或任何这类的事，但我明天要教瑜伽，手机里有音乐。
OK.
好的。
No, I get-- I can make do, I guess. There are bigger problems in the world, I guess.
不，我明白了——我可以应付，我想。世界上还有更大的问题，我想。
Yeah. OK, we're good.
是的。好的，好了。
Want to go back here?
想去那儿吗？
Yep. You can go ahead and go back in there.
对。你可以直接去那儿。
Oh, this room is dirty. I am so sorry.
噢，这屋子很脏。我很抱歉。
That's OK.
没关系。
No, that's fine.
不，没关系。
Not a problem.
不是问题。
All righty, so what I want to do is kind of explain that we do have a search warrant. You're welcome to see the warrant. You're welcome to read the warrant, and then explain a little bit about it. Now, if you're willing to talk to me, I'd like to go through just kind of how this started. Sound good to you?
好的，所以我想做的是，解释一下我们确实有搜查令。欢迎你看搜查令。欢迎你读搜查令，然后解释一下。现在，如果你愿意和我谈，我想了解一下这一切是怎么开始的。这样可以吗？
OK.
好的。
Yes.
是的。
I'm going to take-- right here-- I'm going to take notes.
我要做——就在这儿——我要做笔记。
Where were you born?
你在哪儿出生的？
Alice, Texas.
德克萨斯州，爱丽丝。
Alice, like?
爱丽丝，像？
Like?
像？
Like the girl's name, yeah.
像女孩的名字，是的。
Like the name, OK. And currently you're employed as a contract linguist with Pluribus.
像那名字，好的。那你目前受雇为Pluribus公司的合同语言学家。
Yes.
是的。
OK, how long have you been employed by them.
好的，你受雇多久了？
I started 9 February, 2017.
我2017年2月9日开始的。
OK, and where are you currently assigned?
好的，目前派驻在哪儿？
Currently assigned? Like the NSA 21 code, or--
派驻在哪儿？像NSA 21代码，或者——
You can tell me the building.
你可以告诉我不楼。
OK.
好的。
Because, yeah--
因为，是的——
OK, Whitelaw building, second floor.
好的，怀特劳大楼，二楼。
I'm sorry, what languages you said? I heard--
对不起，你说的是什么语言？我听到的——
Farsi, Dari, Pashto.
波斯语、达里语、普什图语。
OK.
好的。
OK, any other?
好的，还有别的吗？
No.
没有。
I'm kidding. OK. All this stems from a report that we received that you had mishandled classified information, OK? So that's the broad scope of it. My question to you is, does that ring any bells to you whatsoever?
我开玩笑的。好的。这一切源于我们收到的报告，称你泄露了机密信息，好的？这就是大概范围。我问你，这有什么印象吗？
It does now. When I started working at Whitelaw, I had-- do you know PKI passwords?
现在有了。当我刚在怀特劳工作时，我有——你知道PKI密码吗？
Mhm.
嗯。
I had a printed out email in my folder, and I didn't have a desk yet. So I took it with me, passed through security, went to a Starbucks, and then came back, and they looked through it. And unfortunately, that email that I had printed out was classified, and they filed a report for that.
我文件夹里有一份打印出来的邮件，当时我还没有办公桌。所以我带着它，通过了安检，去了星巴克，然后回来，他们检查了一下。不幸的是，我打印出来的那封邮件是机密的，他们因此提交了报告。
And you had gone to Starbucks, come back, and they checked a bag, or they--
你去了星巴克，回来时，他们检查了包，还是他们——
They checked my folder. If you're familiar, with Whitelaw, you go through the turnstiles just to get to the cafeteria in back.
他们检查了我的文件夹。如果你熟悉怀特劳，你就知道去后面的自助餐厅得经过闸机。
All right. You had gone to the cafeteria?
好的。你去了自助餐厅？
Yeah.
对。
So you were in the building, and they nabbed you for--
所以你在大楼里，他们抓住了你，因为——
Yeah.
对。
OK, all right, but you're still in the building.
好的，好吧，但你还在大楼里。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
OK, all right, so what's your work role there at Whitelaw?
好的，好吧，那么你在怀特劳的职位是什么？
Currently I translate graphic documents and then-- yeah, that's all I do-- from Farsi to English.
目前我翻译图形文档，然后——是的，我只做这个——从波斯语翻译成英语。
Graphic documents?
图形文档？
Yeah.
对。
OK. When did you process out of the Air Force?
好的。你什么时候离开空军的？
I processed out of the Air Force December-- December 14, 2016, and up until that time, I had been looking at contracts to try to get my clearance renewed.
我2016年12月14日离开的空军，在那之前，我一直在看合同，试图更新我的安全许可。
OK, and when did Pluribus pick you up?
好的，Pluribus什么时候招你的？
Pluribus picked me up-- I believe they gave me the notification around January-- between 11th and 13th, around that day.
Pluribus招我——我想他们是在1月左右通知我的——在11号到13号之间，大概那天。
OK, all right, so your clearance just kind of passed through.
好的，好吧，所以你的许可算是通过了。
It passed through, yeah.
通过了，是的。
So as far as you're aware, you haven't committed any security violations or anything that you're aware of other than this PKI thing?
据你所知，除了那件PKI的事，你没有犯过任何安全违规行为吗？
Other than that PKI thing, no. I mean, I do print out documents at work, just because it's easier for me to translate them by hand, but then I put them in the bin box. And then they don't get mixed up with my class notes that I take, because they are-- I use pretty paper, so I never take out white paper.
除了那件PKI的事，没有。我的意思是，我确实在工作时打印文档，只是因为手写翻译比较容易。但我把它们放在纸盒里。它们不会和我的课堂笔记混在一起，因为我用的是漂亮的纸，所以我不带白色纸出来。
Got it.
明白了。
Because I know that sounds really dumb, but that's just how I can do it now. After that whole PKI thing, I was like, no more white paper out of the building.
因为我知道这听起来很笨，但这就是我现在唯一能做的方法。经过那次PKI事件后，我心想，再也不带白纸出大楼了。
OK, so you said you printed out stuff.
好的，所以你说你打印过东西。
Yeah, I printed out stuff.
对，我打印过东西。
Is there a-- why did that come to mind, as far as security?
怎么会想到安全性的？
It just-- I guess it all-- I just think about having actual papers. I can't imagine any other way to get things out of the building, I guess, and I'm old fashioned, so I'm just thinking about that. And especially with the PKI thing, just making sure I didn't accidentally have something in my lunchbox or anything like that.
只是——我想是因为——我只是在想拿着真正的纸。我猜不出还有什么别的办法把东西带出大楼，而且我很老派，所以我只是在想那点。特别是有了PKI那件事，只是为了确保午餐盒里没有误带什么东西。
Nothing got out of the building?
没东西带出大楼吧？
Nothing.
没有。
You didn't carry anything out of the building.
你没把任何东西带出大楼。
No. No, I definitely let everything get searched all of the time, so I haven't had any other accidents.
没有。不，我肯定一直让所有东西都经过检查，所以我没发生过别的意外。
OK. Have you ever gone searching for stuff that's not related to your work role?
好的。你有没有搜寻过与你的工作无关的东西？
No. Not unless I have someone in Maryland ask me a question.
没有。除非有人在马里兰州问我问题。
OK. And, I mean, you kind of already answered this, but have you ever taken anything out of the NSA facility. I mean, you mentioned the PKI--
好的。而且，你基本已经回答了这个问题，但你有没有把任何东西带出NSA设施。我的意思是，你提到了PKI——
Yes.
是的。
But have you ever taken anything out of the facility?
但你有没有从设施里带出过任何别的东西？
No.
没有。
No? Whether it's a piece of paper-- you ever downloaded anything? Ever emailed anything out?
没有？无论是纸张——你有没有下载过任何东西？有没有通过电子邮件发送过任何东西？
No.
没有。
No? OK. Have you ever discussed any classified material with anybody who wouldn't have the prior US government authorization?
没有？好的。你有没有和任何没有获得美国政府事先授权的人讨论过任何机密材料？
No.
没有。
No? OK.
没有？好的。
Not many people ask about Iranian aerospace, so I lucked out.
没多少人问伊朗航天的事，我挺幸运。
So you never discussed any work or anything classified with anybody?
所以你从没和任何人讨论过工作或任何机密内容？
Uh-uh. I use a lot of paper, but never anything outside of Iranian and anything else out of that, and never outside of the building.
嗯嗯。我用了很多纸，但绝不是伊朗以外的内容，更不是大楼以外的内容。
OK, Reality, what if I said that I had the information to suggest that you did print out stuff that was outside of that scope?
好的，雷亚蒂，如果我说我有信息表明你打印出的东西超出了那个范围呢？
OK, I would have to remember.
好的，我得回想一下。
OK. What if I said you printed out information that was related to reports on [RUMBLING].
好的。如果我说你打印出的信息与关于[隆隆声]的报告有关呢。
Reality, we obviously know a lot more than we're telling you at this point. And I think you know a lot more than you're telling us at this point. I don't want you to go down the wrong road. I think you need to stop and think about what you're saying and what you're doing, because telling a lie to an FBI agent is not going to be the right thing.
雷亚蒂，我们此时此刻掌握的信息显然比告诉你的要多。而且我想你掌握的信息比告诉我们的也要多。我不想让你误入歧途。我想你需要停下来想一想你正在说什么和做什么，因为对FBI探员撒谎不是正确的做法。
Again, we are here voluntarily. You're talking voluntarily. I'm not asking you, forcing you to do anything but think. That's what I'm asking you to do-- is to think. So think about what he just asked and let--
再说一次，我们是自愿到这儿的。你也是自愿在交谈。我没要求你，没强迫你做任何事，只是让你思考。这就是我要求你的——是思考。所以想一想他刚问你的问题，让——
There was one I printed out because I wanted to read it.
有一份我确实打印了，因为我想读一读。
Can you remember what day you printed it out?
你还记得是什么时候打印的吗？
I might mess up the-- late March, early April, the first two weeks of April.
我可能会搞错——3月底，4月初，4月的前两周。
In the first two weeks of April?
在4月的前两周？
Mhm.
嗯。
And what was it?
那是什么？
It was an NSA Pulse article about [RUMBLING], and yeah, I did. I did print that one out.
那是关于[隆隆声]的一篇NSA简报文章，是的，我确实打印了。我确实打印了那篇。
OK, why'd you print that one out?
好的，你为什么打印那篇？
I wanted to read it, and the way I had downloaded it, it was just hard for me to read. And I wanted to just look at it, because it looked like a piece of history. So I wanted to have that on my desk for a day. And yeah.
我想读一读，而我下载的方式很难阅读。我想读一读，因为它看起来像是一段历史。所以我想把它放在我的桌上放一天。是的。
What did you do with that article?
你拿那篇文章怎么办了？
I kept it on my desk for like three days, and then I burn bagged it in the box that has the slats on it by the fridge.
我把它放在桌子上大概三天，然后我就把它丢进冰箱旁带槽的盒子里碎掉了。
How about any other times?
还有其他时候吗？
Any other times?
其他时候？
Did you search for anything on the [RUMBLING] any other times.
你有没有在其他时间搜索过[隆隆声]上的任何东西。
That did spark my curiosity, so I just kept tabs on reading those articles, looking at the [RUMBLING] was interesting to me. So I did read some of those.
那确实激起了我的好奇心，所以我关注了那些文章，看着[隆隆声]对我来说很有趣。所以我确实读了一些。
OK, did you print out any of those articles? Did you ever go searching for them? Ever go digging?
好的，你打印过那些文章吗？你有没有搜寻过它们？有没有挖掘过？
Nothing more than like a 10 minute detraction from work.
没什么，除了工作之余大概10分钟的消遣。
OK, what were-- how would you do it?
好的，你做了什么——你是怎么做的？
Just type in the search box and scroll.
就在搜索框输入然后滚动。
OK, all right, did you print out any of those articles?
好的，好吧，你打印过那些文章吗？
No. The only one was just the one that was like [RUMBLING].
没有。只有那篇关于[隆隆声]的。
OK. You're pretty sure it was late April, early March. Think about it-- try to remember personal details of your life and your-- OK?
好的。你很确定是4月下旬，3月初。想一想——尽量回想你生活中的个人细节，还有你的——好的？
I know. I'm trying to. So I remember-- I remember that week. I got into a fight with a boyfriend that week. It had to have been sometime in April. I'm just-- I'm trying to think what week-- what weekend after that was like-- I'm sorry. I'm just--
我知道。我正在回想。我记得——我记得那一周。那一周我和男朋友吵了一架。那一定是在4月的某个时候。我只是——我在想之后那个周末是怎样的——对不起。我只是——
No, it's OK.
不，没关系。
I'm trying. Just yeah, like mid-April is all I'm thinking.
我正在想。就是这样，大概4月中旬是我能想到的。
OK. All right. What if I told you that I know you searched for and printed out a document on the 9th of May?
好的。好吧。如果我告诉你，我知道你在5月9日搜寻并打印了一份文档呢？
9th of May? I guess I can't argue that.
5月9日？我猜我不能反驳。
OK.
好的。
I mean, if you-- I, mean obviously you know.
我的意思是，如果你——我意思是，你显然知道。
OK.
好的。
This would have been three and a half, four weeks ago, roughly.
这大概是三个半、四周前的事。
Mhm, yeah.
嗯，是的。
Do you remember what-- how you-- what you did to get to the article?
你还记得你是怎么——你做了什么得到那篇文章的吗？
Other than seeing it on the front page or linking it from another--
除了看到它在首页，或者从其他地方链接过来——
Do you remember what search terms you might have put in?
你记得你可能输入过什么搜索词吗？
Probably [RUMBLING]. I'm not very sophisticated.
可能是[隆隆声]。我不太会用。
OK, so you printed out the doc-- you printed out a document, an intelligence report on this. You do recall that?
好的，所以你打印了那篇文档——你打印了一篇文档，一份关于这个的情报报告。你还记得吗？
Yeah, I do remember now, yes.
是的，我现在记得了，是的。
OK, so what did you do with that document?
好的，那你拿那份文档怎么办了？
Like I said, I kept it on my desk for a couple of days because I thought that it was interesting, and I thought that I would read it. And then I said, no, and I need to not keep this out on my desk. So I put it in the burn bin.
就像我说的，我把它在桌上放了几天，因为我觉得它很有趣，我想我会读读它。然后我说，不，我不能把它留在桌上。所以我把它放进了焚烧箱。
You put it in the burn bag, OK.
你把它放进焚烧袋了，好的。
Yeah.
是的。
All right, Reality, are you sure that's what you did with it?
好了，雷亚蒂，你确定那是你处理它的方式吗？
Yes.
是的。
Are you positive?
你确定吗？
Yes.
是的。
You didn't take it out of the building?
你没把它带出大楼？
No.
没有。
OK, you didn't take it out of the building, give it to anybody else.
好的，你没把它带出大楼，交给任何人。
No.
没有。
You didn't send it.
你没发送它。
No.
没有。
You didn't send it to anybody?
你没把它发给任何人？
No.
没有。
OK. Reality, can you guess how many people might have printed out that document?
好的。雷亚蒂，你能猜到有多少人可能打印了那份文档吗？
No.
不知道。
It's not too many. That document has made it outside, OK? Obviously, because we're here.
没几个人。那份文档已经流传到外面去了，好的？显然，因为我们在这儿。
Yeah, obviously. Crap.
是的，显然。真该死。
The most likely candidate, by far and away, is you. I don't think you are a big bad master spy, OK? I don't. I don't think that. But I think you might have been angry over everything that's been going on politics-wise. Can't turn on the TV without getting pissed off, or at least I can't. And I think you might have made a mistake. Now, why I'm here, and why I want to talk to you is to figure out the why behind this, OK? So I ask you again, did you take it out and send it?
可能性最大的，远超其他人，就是你。我不觉得你是个大坏蛋间谍，好的？我不这么认为。我不这么想。但我认为你可能是因为政治上发生的一切而生气。不打开电视就没法不感到气愤，或者至少我不能。我想你可能犯了个错。现在，我之所以在这儿，之所以想和你谈，是为了找出背后的原因，好的？所以我再问你一次，你把它带出去并发送了吗？
I didn't. I put it in the burn bag. I mean, I'm trying to deploy. I'm not trying to be a whistleblower. That's crazy.
我没做。我把它放进焚烧袋了。我的意思是，我正在尝试部署。我不是在试图成为告密者。这太疯狂了。
So how do you think a document like that would end up getting out?
那你觉得像那样的文档是怎么流传出去的？
I would-- let's be straight. I mean, there's little to no security on documents.
我想——我们说实话。我的意思是，文档基本没什么安全性可言。
OK, but you said you remember. You remember putting it in the burn bag, sliding it in there.
好的，但你说你记得。你记得把它放进焚烧袋，滑进里面。
Folded in half. I mean, I remember it.
对折。我的意思是，我记得。
Folded in half?
对折？
Yeah, because it didn't-- yeah, I folded it in half.
是的，因为它没——是的，我把它对折了。
OK. What if I told you that that document, folded in half, made its way outside NSA?
好的。如果我告诉你，那份对折的文档流传到了NSA外面呢？
I don't know that.
我不知道那件事。
Yeah, made its way out in an envelope postmarked Augusta, Georgia. See, things are getting a little specific.
是的，它装在一个盖着乔治亚州奥古斯塔邮戳的信封里流传出去了。你看，事情开始变得有点具体了。
OK.
好的。
OK, it made its way to an online news source that you subscribe to. Getting really specific. Would you agree? Looks awfully bad.
好的，它流传到你订阅的一个在线新闻源了。变得非常具体了。你同意吗？看起来糟透了。
It looks really bad.
看起来确实很糟糕。
So how'd you get it out of the office?
那你怎么把它带出办公室的？
Folded in half in my pantyhose.
对折塞进连裤袜里。
OK. And what did you do with it?
好的。你拿它做了什么？
Put it in an envelope and sent it to [RUMBLING]. That day, that week, it was just too much to sit back, and watch, and think, why do I have this job if I'm just going to sit back and be helpless? And it did-- it just-- sorry. I just thought that that was the final straw.
放进信封，发给了[隆隆声]。那一天，那一周，仅仅是坐视不理，看着，心想，如果我只是坐视不理并表现得无能为力，我为什么还要这份工作？这简直——抱歉。我只是觉得那是最后一根稻草。
It was just something that just kind of did it? Because you don't seem like the type to do this. I believe it. I want to believe it.
那只是某种事情发生的导火索吗？因为你看起来不像那种会做这种事的人。我相信它。我想相信它。
I'm not. I'm not. I want to go out with our special forces. I mean, that's why I got out of the Air Force. That's why I'm here in Augusta. I wanted my clearance back so I could apply for a deployment, and it was just at a time when I wasn't applying for any deployments. And I had seven or eight months left of a job that didn't mean anything to me, because it's Iran, and I'm a Pashto linguist. What am I doing translating Farsi?
我不像。我不像。我想和我们的特种部队一起出去。我的意思是，这就是我离开空军的原因。这就是我在这儿奥古斯塔的原因。我想要回我的许可，这样我就能申请部署了，当时我没申请任何部署。我还有七八个月的工作，对我来说没什么意义，因为那是伊朗，而我是普什图语语言学家。我翻译波斯语算什么？
And it just-- I just felt really hopeless, and seeing that information that had been contested back and forth, and back and forth in the public domain for so long, trying to figure out with everything else that keeps getting leaked and keeps getting released, why isn't this getting out? Why isn't this getting out there? Why can't this be public?
我只是感到非常绝望，看到那些在公共领域来回争论、争论了那么久的信息，看着所有其他不断被泄露和发布的信息，想弄明白为什么这个没有发布？为什么这没有流传出去？为什么不能公开？
Actors Emily Davis, TL Thompson, and Pete Simpson. As you may know, this was all in the news. The document that Reality Winner leaked to the website The Intercept was an intelligence report confirming Russian hacking in the 2016 election. She's still serving her five year sentence. Sounds design and music for the stage production by Sanae Yamada, and Jimin Breslford. Tina Satter's theatrical adaptation of the FBI transcript is called Is This a Room. They have a tour scheduled. Information at halfstraddle.com.
演员艾米丽·戴维斯、TL·汤普森和皮特·辛普森。如你所知，这一切都在新闻里。雷亚蒂·温纳泄露给“拦截”（The Intercept）网站的文件是一份确认俄罗斯黑客干预2016年选举的情报报告。她还在服五年刑期。舞台制作的声音设计和音乐由萨娜·山田和吉敏·布雷斯福德提供。蒂娜·萨特对FBI记录的戏剧改编名为《这就是个房间》。他们有巡演计划。信息请查阅halfstraddle.com。
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman. The people who put together today's show includes Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Ben Phelan, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼制作。制作今天节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米基·米克、丽娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、本·费伦、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。
Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Kelly Clarke, Craig Hensel, Kendra Hanna, Kendra [? Munroe, ?] Madeleine Ball, Andrew Hagelshaw, and Maria Hernandez. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的执行编辑是黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是戴维·克里斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢凯莉·克拉克、克雷格·亨塞尔、肯德拉·汉娜、肯德拉·[门罗？]、马德琳·鲍尔、安德鲁·黑格尔肖和玛丽亚·埃尔南德斯。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。
And I will end this show about the low hum of menace with this very theme appropriate program note. Just a few hours ago, as I was doing some last editing on the show, I learned that a few days ago I shook hands with somebody who now has symptoms of coronavirus, whose wife is a confirmed case. So the plan is I am going into quarantine myself when I leave the studio today, and we are shutting down our office. Most everybody in our office was already working from home.
我将以这个非常贴合主题的节目说明来结束这一期关于低沉威胁感的节目。就在几小时前，当我正在对节目进行最后编辑时，我得知几天前我和某人握了手，那人现在有了新冠病毒症状，他的妻子是确诊病例。所以计划是，我今天离开录音室后就自我隔离，我们要关掉办公室。我们办公室里几乎所有人都已经在居家办公了。
I just want to say I feel fine. Hopefully I'll stay that way between now and next time I talk to you. Avoid contact with others as much as you can. Stay well, and wash your hands, OK? And by the way, if you're tired of reciting the happy birthday song twice as you wash, turns out one chorus of the song "Stayin' Alive" is the perfect length, and whether you're a brother, or whether you're a mother, just stay alive. Stay alive.
我只想说我感觉很好。希望从现在到下次和你谈话时，我能保持这样。尽可能避免与他人接触。保重，洗手，好吗？顺便说一句，如果你厌倦了在洗手时唱两遍生日快乐歌，事实证明唱一遍比吉斯乐队的《活下去》（Stayin' Alive）副歌长度刚好，不管你是兄弟，还是母亲，只要活着。活着。
[MUSIC - "STAYIN' ALIVE, BEE GEES]
[音乐 - 比吉斯乐队《活下去》]